[Music]
i think
college is meant to be a time when you
decide who you are
and what you're going to do with the
person that you are
college is meant to be a place for
growth
a place where you mature it's meant to
be a place where
you focus when i was looking for a
college
i wanted a place where i wasn't just
going to be learning statistics
and numbers and demographics but i was
going to be learning what it meant
to be a statesman understood the
constitution understood our founding
principles
understood what it meant to be american
i think i was looking most for an
environment where i could grow
and where i could thrive and to come in
contact with truth
[Music]
the thing that i think really sets the
hillsdale college curriculum apart from
other curriculums
is that it's unified in the pursuit of
the truth
the core curriculum has been essential
to really see the world as a complete
picture
in each of the branches of study honing
in on those
specific parts taking apart a specific
discipline in order to put it back
together
into a coherent picture of the world
every form of the curriculum is meant to
be a part of this greater understanding
of the human being and what it means to
be a fulfilled human being whether it's
the science department or the english
department both are interested in the
truth of things
and both are focused on making a fuller
human being
the liberal arts are not as much about
gathering information as they are
learning to be
a right kind of person to land on your
feet no matter where you're thrown
the professors and the students here
occupy the same community of learning
the professors don't see the students as
bodies
in the desks or papers to grade they
they really see minds to train and souls
to cultivate and
they're interested in the student as a
person
they're always full of ideas and ways to
help you and
guide you in your life college path
and they always try to help you improve
i like that i can go to their office
hours whenever i want
i can shoot them on email and they will
reply within 24 hours and even the same
day
some of my favorite moments in classes
at hillsdale have been when the
professors get really excited about
sharing something because they just love
what they're learning they love what
they're doing and they love to share
that
when i came to hillsdale college i
expected that it would be
an uplifting atmosphere for my faith and
not something that would be
torn down or minimized and i wasn't
disappointed at all in that
something i've noticed here at hillsdale
was that faith is openly discussed and
shared
and maybe more so than you would find at
other small colleges with maybe an
explicit religious affiliation
because there you don't have those
boundaries it's something that's
it's not official and yet kind of
assumed and embraced it just comes with
the territory
i knew i wanted to go to a college that
would be
spiritually edifying i knew that i
wanted a place that would be
not safe for my faith but a safe place
to grow
in my faith and i've certainly found
that at hillsdale
when you show up on campus and you start
checking out the
clubs and organizations no matter where
you're looking you're going to be able
to find
something to be involved in i was
surprised to find out that
it was much more fast moving much more
entertaining it wasn't as formal as i
expected
there are a lot of different areas
sports clubs intramurals
my freshman year i was just kind of
swept up in a rush of students going
down to the president's ball
in the garden party things like
paintball
to dance parties to various competitions
homecoming week
and that just gives opportunities for
students across the board
i did not want to go greek when i came
to hillsdale college then i got to know
some of the girls
in kyomega and i just thought that they
were wonderful people they were
supportive and they came to my track
meets i realized i wanted to be like
them i wanted to be more
we say to be womanly always and
discouraged never
that's a part of our symphony and that's
something that i wanted to be
more like you take away a lot from the
classroom but outside the classroom
is really a huge portion of where you
learn about yourself
and how you can contribute to the world
beyond college
i think the pursuit of truth at
hillsdale has fostered such
meaningful and lasting friendships i
think we
call each other to something higher in
that pursuit you know
iron sharpens iron i think hillsdale is
full of a lot of iron
the friends that i have are just
phenomenal i mean
my friends are supporting me like in
school and track and
my sorority i never feel like i'm really
being competed against
trying to understand truth bonds people
together in a way which
very few other things do that's a kind
of cohesion
that can only be found in very few
circumstances
there's always this collaboration of
students just getting together
supporting one another wanting to be the
best that we can be
the friendships at hillsdale have been
among the most edifying
friendships in my life friendships
at hillsdale are forever
[Music]
now that i've been at hillsdale the
thing i've realized i want most out of
college
is an environment in which i'm
surrounded
with people that are going to sharpen me
classes that are going to challenge me
and an environment that grows me and
that's what i found here
there is a lot of fun and there is a lot
of freedom but you're going to be
challenged every single day
to be the best that you can be to stay
accountable and hold your friends
accountable too
college is meant to be a place where we
are prepared
the rest of our life where we are formed
and we are shaped
in order to act as good human beings
with an idea of the true
and the good and the beautiful and i
think that's i think it says a lot more
about human beings than what a lot of
other places
you